we did what we could remember us these
words were written by Dr Mahmud abua on
a wide board normally used for planning
surgeries Doctors Without Borders says
he was killed in the attack on Al AA
Hospital in Northern Gaza a few weeks
ago along with several other doctors and
not just them Israel has also killed
artists Educators entrepreneurs
journalists and athletes losses that are
ripping apart what's left of its Society
many say Israel is waging a war of atide
that is a deliberate targeting of a
community's leadership it was first used
by British journalist Michael Nicholson
in the '90s to describe the Bina
Massacre of mostly Muslims in Bosnia and
heoa by Ser paramilitary groups on the
war on Gaza genocide expert arasa bulus
mik tweeted saying killings of the most
notable of your community are done to
make you remember no body is safe to
make you lose hope to ensure the
community doesn't resist or reorganize
many analysts believe Israel is
attempting to deliberately erase
palestine's identity history and
existence also known as cultural
genocide you remove not only a human
being with all of their sort of
complexity and potential from the Earth
but you take away somebody that has been
um a leader in their cultural field you
destroy those things you remove an
intrinsic part of a people and their
culture from the earth the Palestinian
Ministry of cultures report details the
profound impact of two months of Israeli
bombardment on gaza's cultural sector it
says more than 28 creative professionals
including artists writers and musicians
have been killed by Israeli bombing nine
publishing houses and libraries have
been damaged as well as 21 cultural
centers and at least 20 historical sites
they include theet 's oldest mosque and
the widely known Greek Orthodox sorus
beli to be the third oldest church in
the world according to the Rome statute
targeting historic monuments or
religious buildings intentionally is a
war crime but many say the impact for
Palestinians is bigger than the loss of
physical landmarks it becomes easier to
dehumanize a people to um publicly
present them in a more simplistic or
barbaric or reductive way if you can
eradicate their places of culture and
Community um learning um and I think
that's what we have seen time and time
again from um the Israeli Army and the
Israeli
state for Palestinians it's a daily
fight just to stay alive and to hold on
to their very existence as a people
nadii Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer